it's great to be joined today by Ben
Mezrich who is the mega best-selling
author whose books have been turned into
the movies 21 and the social network I
recently recommended the book that the
movie 21 was based on bringing down the
house and then also has the new book
wooly
now which is I think where we'll start
today Ben for people who have not been
following what's been going on with the
woolly mammoth I mean what how did you
first hear about what was going on and
decide to write about it well I've
always been obsessed with woolly
mammoths and I've also always loved
Jurassic Park and I heard this story a
couple years ago about a scientist in
Boston a guy named dr. George Church
whose lab was attempting to resurrect a
wooly mammoth
so I basically just emailed him out of
the blue and I ended up embedding myself
in his lab at Harvard Medical School and
they are actually making a woolly
mammoth they've taken the they've
harvested the ancient DNA from frozen
woolly mammoth sequenced it and they're
going to place that DNA into the cells
of Asian elephants so that an Asian
elephant gives birth to a woolly mammoth
George church is a very interesting guy
I've interviewed him not not about the
woolly mammoth but about a GMO what what
was your sort of embedding what did the
embedding consist of well I basically
just started hanging out in his lab all
the time and watching it's like Willy
Wonka's factory over there where they're
working on all of these revolutionary
things using genetic engineering you
know they're working on anti malaria
mosquitoes and transgenic mice to beat
Lyme disease and reverse aging and then
one group is working on the woolly
mammoth so I hung out with these
postdocs on a daily basis and I hung out
with George and basically watched it all
in action and from there sort of built
this story about this this revolution
and genetics going on so when you write
a book like this and then maybe after we
can talk a little bit about bringing
down the house what's your process for
sort of developing the total arc of the
book because it's it's nonfiction but as
maybe some of the audience doesn't know
there are some times in your books
fictional elements like in bringing down
the house when you start to craft the
arc do you begin with a full outline do
you flesh out particular anecdotes or
stories that you think would
interesting or how do you how do you do
it yeah so basically I write true
stories but I write them like thrillers
so the first thing I do is do all the
research so I spend all as much time as
they can with the main characters I try
and travel everywhere I try and get the
whole story down once I've got all of
the details down then I create an
outline which is pretty severe it's
basically a thriller outline it has a
three-act system like a movie and I
usually know even the page number for
each chapter that I'm going to write
before I start writing and then I write
I write and I locked myself in my room
and I write for you know a couple months
until it's got a finished book so for me
the outlining is probably the most
intensive stage of the whole game but
the goal is to take all of these true
stories and place them in a structure
that works dramatically so when I'm
interviewing people I'm having them just
tell me stories and I find out how to
figure out how to put all those story
together how do you make certain
decisions and I know I'm starting to get
like really micro here but but and this
is relates to my interest in bringing
down the house which I read not that
long ago you know I read bringing down
the house about the mit blackjack team
and then after reading the book I went
and researched well who are the people
that the book is based on who did Ben
Mezrich actually talk to how much of
this is real and what elements were
fictionalized how do you make a decision
like for example to create a character
in the book that might be an amalgam of
multiple people in real life or the
opposite do you make those decisions
based on how it will serve the telling
of the story or how do you evaluate that
well every case is completely different
when you go back to bringing down the
house I think you're probably talking
about the Kevin Spacey character in the
movie 21 or the sort of the professor
yeah character is based on two people so
I had a main character who essentially
brings me the story in most cases and
he's kind of what the book revolves
around so the real guy was named Jeff
Mon bringing down the house and the book
I renamed him Kevin Lewis he was the
center of the story and then everyone
else kind of filled it in as I interview
that and try and get into the story in
terms of how I choose to make a
composite character sometimes it's
because that what I'm asked to do by the
people who are in the book and don't
want people to
know who they are sometimes it's a it's
a mechanism to tell a story that takes
place over a long period of time and
might involve more than one person in
one role so what I like to say is that
all the facts in the story are true but
they're arranged in such a way to bring
out the dramatic flair of the story so
for instance with bringing down the
house I think there were a lot of
articles written about what was true and
what wasn't true yeah and most got it
wrong the things that people thought
weren't true really were true but you
know some of it was written in a very
dramatic way and the dialogue is
recreated because it took place a long
time ago but in terms of that Mickey
Rossa character he was an amalgam of two
people and and it's it suited you know
telling the story of Jeff ma by
composite composing that character so as
far as what was and wasn't true Abbie
I'm curious to hear from you either the
the universally or very commonly pointed
out elements of bringing down the house
and I'm going to just give a warning if
you haven't read it I am going to talk
about some of the elements that are sort
of towards the end of the book I'm about
to talk about them just in case you
haven't read it and care about this a
hearing about this in advance this sort
this poker chip right this poker chip
that in the book you frame as this sort
of sign that that ends up in someone's
apartment that we've got access to you
that as well as the break-in that takes
place being related to the blackjack
team those are two elements that from my
reading were completely fictional is
that what what's your sense of that now
well the break-in did happen so the
character that in real life were married
a husband and wife team who then Kate
Bosworth ended up playing the blonde
girl in the story the Jill character
yeah her and the guy she was with
apartment was broken into and their
blackjack winnings were stolen so that's
true
whether it was related to Mickey Road so
the professor or the privatise who were
chasing him or just people who knew they
had tons of cash on them is a little bit
more misunderstood the story of the
poker chip was told to me by multiple
people where it fit into the story might
have been different in the chronology
but absolutely they were being followed
by private eyes there was a lot of
people following them and there was a
breakup of the team and what's the two
sides of the team were battling
so it's unknown you know what that
warning was and what it really meant but
no that's all true I mean you can you
can talk to Jeff and I think he goes
back and forth on on his stories here
and there but Jeff maintains you know
all the stories the break-in is
certainly true
the apartment was broken into in their
blackjack winnings were stolen so so
yeah you know those stories are not uh
not untrue in across a number of the
books you've written Boston plays a
pretty prominent role right I mean the
mit blackjack team Facebook start at
Harvard now working with George Church
here in the city for the new book
Woolley is there something in particular
I mean I know you live in the city so in
a sense that's what makes a lot of these
people and stories accessible but is
there something unique sort of flavor
that you think is added to these stories
by virtue of them taking place in Boston
yeah I mean I love the city and I also
feel like Boston is kind of the center
of very smart people who sometimes don't
like Authority
I do think there's this whole sort of
feeling among young people and so many
colleges around here and there's so many
people doing biotech and computers and
robots and everything you can kind of
think of that the cutting edge is
happening here so I've always felt this
is a very fertile place I mean I live
here I've lived here for a very long
time and you don't have to go that far
to find a story you know I run into
people every day you have a great story
but in a lot of ways it is also a
coincidence I mean I ran into the MIT
kids and wrote that story then I got an
email out of the blue from Eduardo's
friend who said my best friend founded
Facebook and no one's ever heard of him
and that became the social network and
then this is the the first book I've
written that was really Boston based
since the social network and this one
you know Leigh there's a woolly mammoth
being made right down the street so I
really had to know about it so in a lot
of ways I just run into these stories in
Boston but I feel like if I lived in
another place I wouldn't run into these
sorts of stories so I don't think I'll
ever leave but yeah I do think there's
something very fertile about Boston on
when a bookie right is turned into a
movie is is the thrill of that or I
guess let me phrase it a different way
does does the story possibly being
distorted from the way you wrote it in
some way
bring down what I'm guessing is a pretty
thrilling experience of seeing these
actors and and film producers take what
you wrote and turn it into a film I mean
what's that experience like well you
know I've been incredibly lucky I mean
the social network is one of the best
movies of the last two decades I would
say and when you find out that Sorkin
and Fincher are going to make a movie
out of your book you know that's an
amazing moment and then the movie was
fantastic 21 was a lot of fun it was
aimed at people who are turning 21 and I
think it's been embraced by a very large
audience and so I've been lucky you know
sooner or later they'll make a horrible
movie out of one of my books and I'm
sure it will be a miserable experience
but so far I've been very lucky wooly is
being made by the guy Marty Bowen who
did Twilight and Maze Runner and we have
a wonderful writer director who's almost
done with the script and I'm involved
very early in the process so I get to be
a part of all the conversations as it's
being developed so you know you never
really know once the movie is shooting
whether what's going to happen but I've
set myself up into a point where I get
to be involved very early so I know
who's being cast but I I get to have a
say and a lot of things but yeah you
don't have control you lose all control
then you get that that check from the
movie studio so you have to sort of hand
it off to the right people but so far
I've been fortunate we've been speaking
with Ben Mezrich the new book of course
is called Wooley check it out then it's
been so great speaking to you I really
appreciate it
hey this was awesome thank you so much